hey guys i'm philip molina and this Erik
Bosse it is Erik Voss and we are going
to talk about a lot of the stuff that
came out at comic-con but it was so much
that we don't have time to do a toy we
normally do it so we're both kind of
just gonna stand up here and give you
maybe a collection of are quite first
thoughts we definitely watch these
trailers mccannon again and again but
just a lot of the first things we
noticed and we're just gonna spit them
right at the camera improv style totally
raw unfiltered genius we're gonna do
Wonder Woman right now but also check
out we're doing Justice League as well
there's a lot of tie in obviously
because the Wonder Woman character
appears in both films so watch that
trailer I break down after you watch
this one or if you already watched it
good job bonus points you ready to get
started let's do it
alright let's do it
you men yeah yeah that look like huh
right off the bat Diana's finding Steve
Trevor who is her like love interest
from the comics these crash-landed on a
beach of what's probably the mascara
this is sticking pretty closely to the
origin story of Steve and Diana meeting
in the comics steve is an American
intelligence officer in some versions
some virgin seas just a pilot American
soldier and if you take a look around
here you can kind of tell that this is
some sort of like interesting mystical
place with these cool like broth
formations out in the water it's gonna
come back later in the trailer actually
but we'll get back to that when we see
it again later for now yeah just it's
worth noting that Diana has never seen a
man before then this guy's like
basically like an alien to her and I
think that really underlies this is an
origin story even though we already saw
Diana in the Batman for Superman movie
there she's like had you know what like
a hundred years to figure that basically
it's like I think I know what a guy
looks like got a weiner but now she has
no idea it's gonna show a more naive
version of Wonder Woman who it's
probably going to change after the
events of this movie and we'll see why
she became hardened and grizzled and I
famine for Superman but this beginning
character she's basically just like a
teen has been kept in the house too long
like him
you have been my greatest love
be careful Diana
I do not deserve you
so we see some more images of Diana's
home island and this woman that's
talking to her is Hippolyta this is
Diana's mother now originally in the
Wonder Woman comics Wonder Woman story
was that she was made out of clay by her
mother and she was endowed with all
these various abilities by different
Greek goddesses but this movies kind of
mixing things up now in the new 52 you
might know that Zeus had a big role in
making weight not with the fist in
making Diana
with follow taught and did a clay story
ended up being just a cover-up for the
big Zeus Hippolyta love affair so the
Hera wouldn't find out here it seems
like the movies kind of like just not
wanting to say exactly know something
the fists that Zeus was that kind of
involved but just like you know what
Zeus played a role I had no father I was
brought to life by Zeus
oh so it's caught up to new 52 I don't
think we're gonna hear the phrase I was
made out of clay right and check out him
while it's his crown in the scene it
looks like that might be the crown that
Wonder Woman wears later the beautiful
day when a mother gives her daughter her
warrior crown I can't wait to get mine
and then moving forward a little bit
more steve is bringing Wonder Woman back
to man's world this looks actually like
the UK and you can see those clips are
kind of familiar if you from there I've
never been there actually I had to look
at pictures but we do know that this is
definitely King's Cross station that's a
really famous London train station from
history and from fake history and Harry
Potter rumor has it that Wonder Woman's
plan to this movie
are to help end the world war that's her
motive for this movie and we're back
with Wonder Woman once again crashing a
party she probably was not invited to
with probably ulterior motives I'm I
guess here is that this German probably
officer I kind of see that cross looks
German he's probably her target for
assassination or something you see she
obviously is about to whip out a
freaking sword that could be Kaiser
Wilhelm which would be really
interesting that's the Emperor of
Germany at this 5:00 and if they were
like oh we could end this war we just
lopped off his head it would totally
change a timeline and flashpoint fans
know that that's bad idea so I'm
thinking it probably is not the
of Germany it could be some other
representation there are some clues that
people are using to say maybe it's
Kaiser that guy famously had this short
shriveled arm which is such like a movie
villain trait by the way it's his left
arm actually a dega but he would always
hide it from public view and note how
the actor here is holding his arm behind
his back maybe cuz it's short and
shrivel but also long famously had his
big ol silly mustache and this guy don't
oh I'm thinking is not well home we
actually have an idea there someone else
it could be that I think would be a
little more interesting right yeah check
out this sword that Diana's planning on
attacking him with now if this guy were
just a human she wouldn't need this cool
magical Amazonian sword to kill him
right super delicate so what if it's not
a human but it's a god in fact we're
thinking it might be the God Ares that's
a God of War and he's a recurring enemy
to Wonder Woman in the comics now we're
thinking that it's possible that he's
taking a human form and manipulating
political events to bring the world
deeper into war that would totally be
aligned with what Ares off out right
it's kind of like Vandal Savage who you
guys might know like always tries to
create more war Ares again the God of
War he wants to create war anywhere he
goes maybe he's behind this whole thing
but also maybe that's not Ares at all
no promises let's keep going
if you never met a man before but what
about your father I had no father I was
brought to life by Zeus oh that's neat
oh so this section first off scares the
crap out of you with masked lady we'll
call her that she actually reminds me a
lot of the guy from Boardwalk Empire
actually after World War 1 there were a
lot of a shell deformities and just in
general people missing limbs and jaws
and whatnot and so they didn't really
have the best surgeons at the time but
they had really good ceramic makers who
would just make these little real creepy
face masks but I guess it's better than
a gaping hole
speaking of gaping halls but what about
your father
I had no father I was brought to life
places there's this comedy moment
between Wonder Woman and Steve where she
says that I don't have a father Zeus
brought me to life and he's just like oh
that's neat and I think this is cool cuz
we're seeing this comedy interplay
between a human and a mythological
demigod and that really reminds me of
what made Thor so great in that first
Thor movies so this is another origin
story with a mythological demigod
totally as a fish out of water uh what's
really interesting that while I requites
off kylo is that Steve Trevor here is
walking away from my German I'm gonna
call it a Fokker plane he's holding
these goggles clearly it was just in
flight so was he just flying a German
plane and if so then he landed maybe on
a German base maybe undercover and I
would love that if there's a whole like
undercover spy plot line in this movie I
think it would fit these characters
really well but also it would set it
apart from just the you know Titans
clashing that we've seen so far from DC
it has a almost like James Bond in World
War 1 element to it which but like quick
thing Chris Pine was once considered for
James Bond which made no sense because
he was American moving on
I'm also picking up where it looks like
maybe right after that attempted
assassination mission we don't know if
it goes well or not she's riding off on
a horse I think it maybe is right after
that because it looks like her blue
dress flies off and don't be a pervert
she got her armor hunt underneath and
then it's worth noting uh she's on a
horse and you're like doesn't Wonder
Woman fly in a lot of her origin section
she doesn't fly actually in one version
I think she gets like a feather from
Hermes and pokes herself with it that
makes her fly I don't know how though
but at least for right now it looks like
she's stuck on the ground okay so next
up in this section we see this Amazonian
warrior flying through the air we're
thinking this might be Robin Wright's
character she plays this badass aunt -
Diana and they're fighting off the
mascara with these human soldiers so
we're thinking these might be soldiers
that are chasing Steve Trevor to the
island I actually have an idea for who
exactly they are on what exactly is
happening there the rock formations are
back up their mascara I think this is
all part of that section we see at the
beginning when Steve Trevor lands I
think he maybe stole one of those planes
and maybe got chased by the rest of the
Germans and they follow in here
crash-landed Germans vs. Amazonians
badass battle at the beginning of the
movie as my guess we'll get further in
the trailer and we'll connect back to
this exchange but I just gotta say holy
crap up and right looks ripped on
horseback look at her arms do you see
the way she dispatches that guy I'm
pretty sure she was in flight with the
arrows before somebody I think takes her
bow and she just uses all the arrows as
a masked knife weapon and just stabs him
with all the arrows and the guy behind
her is smiling because he knows it's
amazing also keep in mind that Robin is
a big-name actress and very talented at
that I don't think she's just gonna
appear in these early scenes on famous
gear point is she's way too talented to
just keep at the beginning of the movie
yeah she's probably gonna come back in
some way we don't really want to say how
because it might end up being a spoiler
but hang in there Robin right you're
probably in the more of this movie than
we've seen then moving on
so in this section we're outside of cafe
booby
it's a French cafe but I think this is
still in Germany that's the German word
for beer in the German word for tobacco
I think most of the movie actually
probably takes place in Germany and zoom
in right there look at that is that
Steven Diana
doing a little dance yeah it seems like
they're practicing for maybe that dance
saying that we see later in the movie
like maybe this is the time where it's
like oh well I don't know your human
ways
me the ways of danger your ways of dance
then I have subs I want to point out
really quick that shield that Wonder
Woman uses in this section here that's
not the shield that stop doomsday a lot
of people think it's the same shield I'm
gonna say that there's actually a story
there with why she has two different
shields but it's definitely the same or
all right so let's move on
alright so in this next section we're
seeing one woman walk out into the
famous trench warfare of World War one
now this reminds me a lot of another
Marvel movie Captain America the First
Avenger
that was another period war film in a
different world war that was world war
ii and i'm thinking maybe that's why
they place Wonder Woman in World War 1
because they thought World War 2 has
already kind of been done in a superhero
movie also I take that red sign right
there says do not stand about here even
if you're not hit somebody else will be
that sign was up on specifically British
trenches so I think a lot of the movie
like I said meticulous in Germany but
also we can see British fight even
though Steve Trevor's American we're
gonna be with British forces you got a
British secretary that we see later but
also I just want to point out something
here too about these trenches and
everyone being down below but Wonder
Woman up above so the area above
trenches that's known as no-man's land
like that phrase is associated with just
the place where you're not really
protected no man should walk up there
because he's gonna get shot or blown up
so isn't it incredibly appropriate
actually that Wonder Woman is the one
walking into the land that no man can
enter I definitely feel like that's also
on purpose you got to remember World War
one is not the much later World War two
when women were kind of given a shot in
the hole rosie the riveter kind of feel
that air of like Oh women are stepping
up this is way before that so it's just
that much more interesting that they're
putting a very powerful woman way before
anyone's seen that in battle especially
at that time
I cannot do this
what I do is none up to you
I've done this section they're hanging
out in a bar and this kind of feels to
me like it could be an inglorious
basterds situation where maybe they're
undercover ask again and don't want to
be outed but they are hence the gun and
hence Tana effortlessly knocking this
would-be assassin out look at her face
let's go like frame by frame on that
face that is the definition of no effort
or a definition of boredom okay yeah but
check out this quick shot of this
explosion as the group lines up against
the wall those people are the same
people that we saw in the photo back in
Batman vs Superman and that awesome
email attachment that Wonder Woman
received so it seems like the picture
that we saw will be taken at some point
during the sequence yeah in fact you can
kind of see those buildings look like
the same buildings in the background of
that photo I feel like it's like hey
take a picture click oh we're suddenly
in a battle or the other way around
probably the way I said though because
you wouldn't take a picture at the end
of a battle like whew smile right okay
also in the scene we've seen the famous
glowing lasso of truth that's the
indestructible lasso that Wonder Woman
uses to force people to tell the truth
and she's using it too like a liver the
truth and it's just like a normal Lassa
yeah all right but then also there's
more dancing I think it's maybe the
payoff to the practice dancing earlier
it's also probably in that assassination
attempt and we get this line okay and
then the sassy reply but I do stop to
you it's a cool line it's a very
empowering moment but it's also funny if
this is happening while they're dancing
that's something that you traditionally
you take a man's lead while you dance
and the fact that he's like oh I'm
leading this situation she's like no
Mike steps on his toe too at the same
moment let's go back and focus on one
moment in this section where Steve takes
this German plane that we saw him
walking away from earlier I'm wondering
if this is like we were saying earlier
part of the opening of the movie uh
where Steve might be undercover on a
mission to steal some kind of
information from the enemy
posing as a German soldier and escaping
a crash landing on the island a
beautiful island with beautiful women
who are all murderous then I so Steve he
like once under a wing at one point and
that plane just was making us realize
like oh yeah German pilots are a big
deal in World War one I mean Red Baron
is this famous character but also famous
characters enemy ace and that is a
potential villain that we have really
seen anything about anywhere but could
definitely be a good wartime villain or
we might get a villain at least kind of
like that and one more thing when we're
talking about these shots of the planes
these shots of Steve shooting up all the
other German planes might be setting up
for some dog fight scenes and playing on
plane battles that would be really cool
to see it also reminds me of that scene
in the force awakens where Finn steals a
TIE fighter and uses it to shoot up all
the other Thai fighters that would chase
him it's a real smart escape plane I
want to point out that that armored
truck that gets like oh it actually was
in that shot way earlier where they're
dancing in front of which is like again
the most confusing order for what order
things might happen here like hey we're
in a huge battle we should take a
picture and then slow dance I have no
idea exactly what's going on there but
let's just say that that cafe section
probably is gonna be a huge moment one
of the bigger set pieces of the movie we
also see a lot of shots of Wonder Woman
jumping into this warehouse looking flat
and she just tears up the joint it's
awesome it's so badass is she looks like
when Batman was taking down all the guys
in the warehouse in Batman vs Superman
just one of the cooler fights in that
movie you know my favorite part was
there what freaking rifle behind her
back and her like what breaks the the
rifle half don't even out to see it only
[ __ ] rifle only show gal gadot doing it
not Eric so this gals good don't he
doesn't know what he has brought that
good ice candy I'm at Steve Trevor's
secretary what is a secretary I go where
he tells me to go when I do what you
tells me to do
I'm where I'm from that's called slavery
I really like her fantastic ladies after
you into I did mine and then I just
wrapping it up here the little Taggy
right at the end with cute little Etta
candy I might have a thing for like
little tiny British women she is a
Wonder Woman's best friend from the
comics she's in pretty much every
version of the Wonder Woman comics she's
also Steve's secretary like she is in
this movie she
he actually ends up marrying Steve and
some was spoiler in the comics probably
not in this movie though I would love
that and in which like Diana I've
enjoyed our time together but you made
me realize that I really want is the
opposite of an Amazonian warrior
princess alright so these were the
things that we noticed upon watching
this I think that this movie honestly
looks pretty freakin good like I was
hesitant I was like oh they're gonna do
another chill war movie but honestly it
kind of won me over just this trailer
alone so now I'm super excited for it
moved to probably top in my list but let
us know definitely if there are things
you pointed out like I said earlier we
kind of had to knock this one out as
fast as we could so I wouldn't be
surprised if we missed a thing or two if
we did I would love to hear it I you can
hit me up at fimo on Twitter to let me
know some small stuff you can hit me up
on Twitter a ta vas to let me know some
big stuff what I'm most well because you
can put longer messages to me on my
Facebook page facebook.com slash fimo
nose or regular-sized stuff I don't like
talking about stuff so much follow add
new rock star sue to find out when these
videos come out yeah subscribe to our
channel if you aren't subscribed already
at new rock stars here hit subscribe
yeah uh and then check out our Justice
League trailer breakdown she's in that
movie too so if you like her you should
definitely watch that too and we're
gonna do the same thing in fact we're
gonna shoot it right now I just go over
real quick and just let you know some of
the extra stuff that we noticed
hopefully some same things that you guys
notice and finally I if you want to
support us and doing these kinds of
things it's patreon.com slash new rock
stars it's the reason why we were able
to shoot this video today are those
donations make a huge impact so thank
you for the people that do it already
and thank you for anyone else is
thinking about doing it so go ahead and
click the link to check that out thank
you so much bye bye